hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to do a website review
from one of my readers Linden who sent
me a link to his site holistic high tech
comm so we're gonna check it out and see
what kind of advice wouldn't give them
so here we go it loads so at first
glance I'm not really sure what this
business does this is weaving the
internet into the fabric of your
business but I'm not quite sure what you
do as a business so I see a couple of
stock photography photos I definitely be
clearer here so let's read a little bit
more see what it says welcome holistic
health practitioner every day you listen
to clients needs visions cleary business
earns you money getting a client's it's
missing if a website is not like present
so okay so I guess you're helping health
practitioners get websites I would
definitely change this around and to
start and make it really clear right
from the beginning what you do so you
know we help help particulars get set up
online we're talk about the different
pains and frustrations of people who are
trying to do it themselves and how you
can step in and provide a professional
service to help them out it's actually a
really good service and one that's
really needed because a lot of these
health practitioners you know they're
really experts of what they do and
they're not experts in website design
and this is an opportunity for you to
really help them out so it's a it's a
really value I'd serve as a thing but
you might want to do a better job
clearly explaining what you do so it's
easier for them to understand so what
else does your online presence
authentically describe what you do well
okay so part of it is also start
describing what you do to write that'll
make it easier for them to understand
what you're all about let's click on
little few more links to see what the
about page is all about so you've
dedicated your company your life online
presence your store and this is great so
it's really good to tell your story and
this looks like it goes on so that's
that's awesome people like to buy from
people and the more you can weave your
own person
a story and why you got into it and have
something that people can relate to
easily the easier it is to get people to
want to take that next step with you
because you look authentic so the one
thing I would probably add here is a
picture so I don't see your picture
anywhere so I definitely put a picture
of yourself smiling happy Linden
definitely right here at the top and
then maybe a few more pictures coming
down this is a lot of text to read so I
definitely split it up with maybe sub
headlines with bigger bigger fonts and
some more pictures of you maybe there's
some easy sections you can divide this
into but it's great that you have a
story a lot of companies don't do this
and I think you really should something
like this my vision could be much bigger
the picture of you writing your vision
or thinking about your vision or telling
somebody about your vision I just try to
add a little bit more to it but this is
a this is a fantastic start looking a
little bit more I see that you have a
subscribe box here this is great I don't
know what you're gonna be sending people
but again you it's a great idea that the
thought is great you want people to sign
up your email it's a fantastic way to
keep in touch with people and turn
somebody from just a visitor into having
an ongoing relationship with you what I
definitely want to put here is just you
know telling them what they're going to
receive so I don't know how many
subscribers you've gotten it's probably
pretty low i would say no talk about
what they're going to get if it's a
monthly weekly newsletter whatever it is
some of the benefits that are attached
to it maybe you give some kind of free
white paper or free download to
encourage them to want to sign up to
start with for example if you had you
know the 10 biggest mistakes health care
practitioners make when starting up
online get it for free when you
subscribe to our newsletter and then
provide lots of our in the newsletter as
well that's a good hook that you can get
people to want to leave their email and
name so great and it's it you above the
fold easy to see just make sure you're
you're offering a little bit more value
and explain what you do to get more
people actually following it up with you
and that's something you can also offer
as a service later on I guess to your
clients is even doing the same thing for
them
from an SEO perspective of something
you're asking about i definitely look at
your title tags so let's start at the
home page so your title tag adjust
holistic high tech now this is not
probably a really you know high no money
keyword for you I try to target
different keywords that you think might
bring in some business so your most
important keyword you definitely put on
your homepage and then also talk about
that content here on your site so i
don't know if it's you know holistic
health care website color is not
something that's going to be searched
that often you're also small websites
it's hard to go after the the big super
competitive names because you're in a
competitive market but if you need [ __ ]
and go after the various practitioners
that are potential clients for you then
that could really help so let's maybe
learn a little bit more about your
clients see what kind of content you can
create so again a lot of texts you might
want to put some pictures in here or
make some would make this a little bit
bigger so it stands out a little bit
more makes it easier to read but this is
great here it's a target audience so you
know acupuncture is energy healers
fitness trainers I think about what is
the most important one and maybe one or
two and put that on your homepage and
then also try to optimize and create
content around each of these so you know
instead of just trying to rank for
websites you're trying to rank for
websites for energy healers or websites
for holistic nutritionist for each one
of this you should have its own landing
page has content that's specifically
interesting and valuable for each of
your different types of clients so it
may not be a very popular keyword for
websites for energy healers but people
who are searching for that but probably
energy healers who need a website so
it's really targeted and if it's not too
competitive it's probably easy to rank
for so I definitely create pages for
each of these targeted at each of these
groups because somebody who's a you know
organic farmer is not going to type
energy healer websites right and they
may not type holistic health websites
which is what you're kind of viewing
your business around so I would
definitely go specific and create a
landing page for each one and create
ongoing content
you have a blog here so let's check that
out quickly so good you have content
here on your blog let's see what you've
got is read this entry that may be a few
too many social media icons on that last
page that we saw there but so health
freedom Expo okay now this is the most
recent blog post and it's from april
2011 i'm sitting here it's June 2012 or
when this video came out it may be
really July we'll see but that's still a
long time so you definitely want to have
more content up here posted regularly I
try for at least once a week the length
is good a lot of times people post
content that's too short so that's great
and you have responses which is
fantastic so a lot of people have a hard
time getting people to respond to their
blog post so it's great that you
promoted it I definitely just try to get
more frequency and you could even cut
that down a little bit you'll see how
many words it is that you're probably
pretty good you want to look at 500
words plus so that's a good amount but
just look at creating the schedule and
trying to post once a week and make sure
you have some kind of call to action
here so for people who are visiting the
site now this is of interest to somebody
and the you know potentially then need
some services have something here one
sentence at the end to say you know you
can contact me here or to learn more
about our services click here I'd also
show related post so show other stuff
that you've written so somebody lands on
this page from a search then they'll be
able to look at a couple more of your
posts really easily that are highly
targeted and related to the one they
read before making a decision to
subscribe to your newsletter or to
contact you so overall I think it's a
very you needed service for the group
that you're going after I think you've
kind of got a good start going on here
but could use some work following those
suggestions that I laid out for those
are watching I hope you enjoyed if you
like the video please give me a thumbs
up it always makes me happy it makes you
want to do more of these videos for you
guys and if you have a comment about
this web
I love to hear from you if you want to
leave a comment or if you have a
question about your website or question
or anything that we talked about here
today feel free to leave it in the
comments below and I'll see you on the
next episode
you